ANDREW HUBERMAN: Welcome
to the Huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science
and science-based tools
for everyday life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I'm Andrew Huberman and I'm
a professor of neurobiology
and ophthalmology at
Stanford School of Medicine.
Today is an ask me
anything or AMA episode,
which is part of our
premium subscriber content.
Our premium channel was launched
in order to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel,
which still comes out
once a week, every Monday,
and of course is zero cost to consumer.
The premium channel is also designed
to support exciting research being done
at major universities like
Stanford and elsewhere,
research that's done on
humans that should lead
to protocols for mental
health, physical health,
and performance in the near future.
If you'd like to check out
the premium channel subscription model,
you can go to hubermanlab.com/premium.
And there you can
subscribe for $10 a month
or $100 a year.
We also have a lifetime subscriber option.
For those of you that are
already Huberman Lab podcast
Premium subscribers and you're
watching and or hearing this,
please go to hubermanlab.com/premium
and download the premium podcast feed.
And for those of you that are not already
Huberman Lab Premium podcast subscribers,
you will be able to hear
the first 15 minutes or so
of this episode and
hopefully that will allow you
to discern whether or not
you would like to become
a premium subscriber.
Without further ado, let's get
to answering your questions.
And as always, I will strive
to be as accurate as possible,
as thorough as possible, and
yet as concise as possible.
The first question is
about how to improve sleep.
In particular, how to improve deep sleep
that is sometimes called slow-wave sleep.
This was a question that
was asked by Jack Pritchard
and they got a lot of up votes.
Now, we've done multiple
full-length episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast on sleep
and tools to improve sleep,
including the Master Your Sleep episode
and Perfect Your Sleep episode,
as well as a toolkit that is available
completely zero cost at hubermanlab.com.
It's a downloadable PDF that lists out
the behavioral tools and other tools
that you can implement
to improve your sleep.
Now Jack's question is specifically about
how to improve deep sleep.
He asks, I have a sleep
analyzer and I typically observe
that I get a lot of REM sleep,
that is rapid eye movement sleep.
For him, he says it's
30% of his total sleep
is rapid eye movement sleep.
But he asks, my deep sleep
is often low, around 10%,
and I would like to know if there
are any science-backed protocols
I can use to specifically
increase my deep sleep.
Okay, so for those of
you that may not know
what is deep sleep.
Now, deep sleep is sometimes
referred to as slow-wave sleep,
that is slow-wave sleep and
deep sleep are sometimes used
interchangeably to
describe the same thing.
They aren't necessarily the same thing,
but they fall under the
same mechanistic umbrella.
What is that mechanistic umbrella?
Well, when you go to sleep at night,
you cycle through a number
of different stages of sleep.
And in the early part of the night,
I would say in the first
half of your night or so,
most of your sleep is going
to be slow-wave deep sleep.
But then as you transition
into the second half
of your night, more of your sleep
will be rapid eye movement sleep.
Now that's the typical pattern
that is observed when
you're not disrupting
your sleep architecture with things
like caffeine and alcohol.
We'll talk about caffeine
and alcohol in a few minutes.
Deep sleep, aka slow-wave sleep,
at least for sake of this conversation,
is vitally important in particular
for repair of bodily tissues.
During deep sleep, you
secrete growth hormone
and in fact you secrete
growth hormone every night
when you go to sleep.
But most of that growth hormone release
is restricted to the first
half of your sleep night.
The other feature of deep sleep
is that the dreams that
occur during deep sleep
tend to be of a less emotional nature
than the sorts of dreams
that one experiences
in rapid eye movement sleep.
So just to give a broad top
contour of what deep sleep,
aka slow-wave sleep is really about,
it tends to occur in the
first half of the night,
it also occurs in the
second half of the night,
but in the first half of the night,
most of your sleep is going
to be occupied by deep sleep,
aka slow-wave sleep.
It is the time when your
bodily tissues are repaired
in part by release of growth hormone,
which is involved in metabolism,
but also protein synthesis, muscle repair,
repair of all cell types and tissues.
And during deep sleep,
your dreams tend to be somewhat mundane,
sometimes a little bizarre,
but typically not very emotionally loaded.
That can change if you're dealing
with a lot of emotionally
laden circumstances
in your waking life, but in general,
the sleep and dreams that
occur in the first part
of the night is deep
and it's not terribly emotionally ridden.
Your body also goes through
specific patterns of metabolism.
Now, this relates to recent
findings just this last year
in which researchers monitored
the output of people's breath
and the various metabolic
factors present in the breath
as well as through blood draws,
So basically doing all this
while people are asleep in a laboratory.
And they observe that during
the first half of the night
while people are in deep sleep,
their body is actually metabolizing
energy very differently
than it does in the
second half of the night.
I'll come back to this in a little while,
but this turns out to be very important
for establishing your metabolism
and the way you regulate
insulin and blood glucose
during the daytime.
So all of this is to say that
getting sufficient deep sleep,
slow-wave sleep, is vitally important.
And Jack's asking how he
can increase the amount
of deep sleep that he's getting because
by his sleep tracking method,
he's observing far less deep sleep
than rapid eye movement sleep.
Now that raises the question
of how much deep sleep
one should be getting overall.
In general, the goal should be to balance
the total amount of slow-wave sleep
and rapid eye movement
sleep across the night.
However, I would not want people to obsess
over getting exactly 30%
rapid eye movement sleep
and exactly 30% slow-wave sleep.
Your body is much more
resilient than that,
but the closer those two
numbers are to one another,
the better overall
architecture of your sleep.
And he doesn't list out exactly
how he's measuring his sleep
so I do want to put an
asterisk on both the question
and the answer I provide by stating
that a lot of sleep trackers,
whether or not they are
WHOOP trackers or Ouras
or whether or not you're
using a mattress based
or mattress cover based sleep tracker
like Eight Sleep or other,
is using heart rate and
heart rate variability
and body movement to estimate
or to kind of predict whether or not
you're in slow-wave sleep
or rapid eye movement sleep.
And that's because during
rapid eye movement sleep,
you tend to be in what's called atonia,
you tend to be paralyzed, you can't move.
And during slow-wave
sleep, that's not the case.
But no matter what the
sleep tracking method is,
if it's a standard commercial
sleep tracking method,
WHOOP or Eight Sleep, et cetera,
it is an estimate or a best guess
at what stage of sleep you're in.
Whereas when you go
into a sleep laboratory,
like the sleep laboratory at Stanford,
at University of Pennsylvania or other
of the great sleep laboratories
that are out there,
they're going to use other methods
including EEG and EMG.
These are just acronyms that refer to ways
to record brainwaves.
They actually are going to try and observe
for rapid eye movements
beneath the eyelids, et cetera.
So sleep trackers give you a best guess
as to what stage of sleep you're in.
They are not perfectly accurately,
at least none of the
commercially available
sleep trackers are perfectly accurate.
So we do want to highlight that.
Okay, so now let's answer
Jack's question directly,
which is how to increase the total amount
of slow-wave sleep.
Well, there are a couple ways.
First of all are the don'ts
and then we'll talk about the dos.
Two things that you can
do to really disrupt
your slow-wave sleep
are to drink alcohol
within eight hours prior
to bedtime or even at all.
Some people will find
that even if they have
a glass of wine or a beer with lunch,
that the amount of slow-wave sleep
and sometimes even the
rapid eye movement sleep
that they get at night is reduced
and that their overall sleep
architecture is disrupted.
This has been shown again and again.
Likewise, avoiding caffeine within eight
and ideally within 12 hours of bedtime
would be preferable.
And if you're not a caffeine drinker,
obviously you don't have
to worry about this at all,
but avoiding caffeine intake
within that 8 to 12 hours
of bedtime will greatly assist in you
getting more slow-wave sleep
and higher quality rapid
eye movement sleep.
This has been shown again and again.
And as well avoiding cannabis use
and maybe even CBD use
within 8 to 12 hours of sleep
can be very beneficial if your goal
is to improve the quality of your sleep.
Now, I know a lot of
people rely on alcohol,
cannabis and CBD in
order to get into sleep.
However, it's been shown
many times in human studies,
and this was discussed
in the podcast episode
that we did with the great Matt Walker,
who's a professor of
neuroscience and psychology
at University of California, Berkeley,
and a world expert in
sleep and sleep science.
Matt and I discussed the research showing
that even though alcohol
helps you fall asleep,
even though cannabis can
help you fall asleep,
and even though CBD can
help people fall asleep,
that it does disrupt
and in many ways reduce
the quality of sleep that one gets.
So that's disappointing news I know
for a number of the people
that rely on cannabis,
CBD, or alcohol to fall asleep,
but I would encourage you
to check out the episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast that we did
about alcohol and about cannabis,
including some of the
health benefits of cannabis
in certain situations,
but also some of the detrimental effects
of both alcohol and
cannabis in other situations
in particular for
improving slow-wave sleep.
So that's actually three major don'ts.
Avoid caffeine, alcohol, and cannabis,
and let's put under the
umbrella of cannabis,
THC and CBD in the 8 and
ideally within the 12 hours
prior to sleep if your goal is to improve
the total amount of slow-wave
sleep that you're getting
and your overall sleep architecture.
In addition,
it's well known that avoiding food intake
in the two hours prior to sleep
is going to greatly assist in the amount
of growth hormone output that you achieve
during the early stages of the night
and the depth and duration
of slow-wave sleep.
Now, I want to place an
asterisk on that statement
by saying if you go to sleep too hungry,
it can also disrupt your sleep.
So you're going to have to
arrange your eating schedule
and your sleeping schedule such that
you're not eating too close to bedtime,
but you're also not going to bed so hungry
that you can't fall asleep
or that you don't get
into deep sleep and stay asleep.
I can personally attest to the fact
that if I'm too hungry,
I can't fall asleep.
Now for me, most nights
I'm going to eat dinner
sometime between 6:00 PM and 8:00 PM
depending on time of year, schedules,
what's going on, traffic, et cetera.
And I tend to go to sleep
somewhere between 10:00 PM
and 11:00 PM plus or minus an hour,
again, depending on time of year
and what else is going on in life.
So I normally have that
buffer of two hours or so
before going to sleep.
However, there are some nights
where even if I eat dinner around 7:00 PM,
I'm quite hungry at 9:00 PM
and I want to go to sleep.
In that case, eating a
small amount of food,
ought not to disrupt your
slow-wave sleep too much,
but you do want to
avoid eating large meals
right before going to sleep unless,
unless completely fasting
and not eating something
late at night will
prevent you from getting
into any sleep at all.
In other words, it's better to make sure
that you're getting to sleep
than it is to avoid food
just so that you get
increased growth hormone output
and into slow-wave sleep.
I hope that's clear.
You know, I have had times in my life
where I'm working very, very hard
and I missed dinner or something comes up
and I know some people can
fall asleep quite easily
on an empty stomach.
I've been able to do that,
in particular if I'm very exhausted.
I also rely on a handful of supplements
to fall asleep each night,
although I've not dependent on them.
There have been times when I
haven't been able to access
those supplements and I
can still fall asleep.
But the point is that you
don't want to be so hungry
that you can't fall asleep.
And yet in an ideal circumstance,
especially if you're trying to increase
the amount of slow-wave sleep,
you would avoid food
in the two hours or so
before going to sleep.
If you can avoid food for
the three or four hours
prior to sleep and still
fall and stay asleep easily,
that's even better for sake
of increasing slow-wave sleep
and growth hormone output.
Now, there are some additional tools
for improving slow-wave sleep,
in particular, the transitions
between slow-wave sleep
and the other sleep stages
because even though,
as I mentioned earlier,
the early part of your
night is occupied primarily
by slow-wave sleep, all night long
you're transitioning from slow-wave sleep
into an intermediate stage of sleep
and then into rapid eye movement sleep
and then back again.
It's just that in the
early part of the night,
more of that time is going to be occupied
by slow-wave sleep.
The two ways to improve slow-wave sleep
that are well documented
in the literature,
and here we can point to
some really nice papers
that I'll reference in case
you want to read further,
is the first one is entitled,
Exercise Improves the
Quality of Slow-Wave Sleep
by Increasing Slow-Wave Stability.
Slow-wave Stability has to do with,
as researchers call it,
the amount of power present
in the different aspects
of slow-wave sleep,
So this gets a little bit technical,
but this is an instance in
which they brought subjects
into the laboratory, they
measured brainwaves by EEG,
they had some other measurements as well
included in subjective measures of sleep,
and they looked at whether or not people
were doing exercise or not prior to sleep.
Now, when I say prior to sleep,
I mean not within six
hours prior to bedtime.
In fact, exercising
intensely in the six hours
prior to bedtime, for
many people, not all,
but for many people can
disrupt the total amount
of slow-wave sleep that they get
and can also disrupt
rapid eye movement sleep.
So the conditions of the study
were pretty straightforward.
It was a randomized crossover trial.
Basically, they had people either sleeping
and monitoring their sleep
or they had people doing
an hour of exercise at 60%
of their so-called VO2
max, you can look this up,
for 60 minutes.
60% of their VO2 max,
that was the intensity.
It's breathing pretty hard,
but not extremely hard.
If we were going to map
that to the so-called zone,
zone 2 cardio being the kind of cardio
you can do steady state
while holding a conversation.
This would be somewhere
in the probably zone 3
or zone 4, although that's not exactly
what 60% of VO2 Max is
going to map to every time.
Think about relatively
challenging cardiovascular output
for 60 minutes, and they had them do that
at least six hours prior to bedtime,
and, this is an important and,
They did have the subjects in this study
in all conditions abstain
from caffeine and alcohol,
so that's very important.
And what they observed was an enhancement
of slow-wave sleep.
So exercise of this sort turns out
to be a very potent form of
improving slow-wave sleep.
Now, I do not know, because the study
as far as I know has not been done,
whether or not doing resistance training
or some other type of exercise
would've led to the same effect,
although I have to imagine
that if it's moderately intense
to intense resistance training
provided it's done far enough
away from going to sleep
prior to six hours before sleep,
that one ought to see the same effects.
Although that was not a
condition in this study.
But it's a very nice study.
They looked at everything from changes
in core body temperature
to caloric expenditure.
They didn't see huge changes in core body
temperature changes, so that
couldn't explain the effect.
It really appears that the major effect
of improving slow-wave sleep was due
to something in changing
the fine structure
of the brain waves that
occur during slow-wave sleep.
In fact, and this is an important point,
the subjects in this study
did not report subjectively
feeling that much better from their sleep.
So you might say, well then why
would I even want to bother?
However, it's well known
that getting sufficient
slow-wave sleep is important
not just for repair,
excuse me, for repair of bodily tissues,
but also for repair of brain tissues
and repair and wash out
of debris in the brain.
And that debris is known to
lead to things like dementia.
So getting the best
quality slow-wave sleep
is extremely important
for body and for brain.
And getting an hour of exercise
that's moderately intense and making sure
that you're not doing that exercise
within the six hours prior to bedtime,
and avoiding caffeine and alcohol,
certainly within the six
hours prior to bedtime,
but I would say in the 8 to 12 hours
prior to bedtime would be even better
or not drinking alcohol at all,
or I know there are people out there
that don't drink caffeine at all,
I'm not one of those people,
but restricting that caffeine intake to
the very early part of the day,
that has been shown to improve the quality
and the overall architecture of sleep
and slow-wave sleep in particular.
That's really what this study points to.
There's another tool that
can improve the amount
and quality of slow-wave sleep
that you achieve at night.
This is actually a tool
that I've started using
over the last six to eight months or so.
As many of you know,
I believe in getting behaviors right
before embracing changes
in supplementation
or prescription drugs.
Behavioral tools consist
of dos and don'ts,
and the dos and don'ts for sleep
are well documented in
the Master Sleep episode
and the Perfect Your Sleep episode
and the toolkit for sleep.
They include getting morning
sunlight in your eyes
or bright light of other kinds,
avoiding bright light
from 10:00 PM to 4:00 AM,
et cetera, et cetera.
All that information is
in the toolkit for sleep
and those other full-length episodes
of the Huberman Lab podcast.
Now, there are supplements
that can greatly improve
the depth of your sleep
and that can shorten the
latency to fall asleep.
And here I'm not referring to melatonin,
as many of you perhaps already know,
I'm not a fan of melatonin
for a variety of reasons,
mainly the fact that most
melatonin supplements out there
don't actually contain the
exact amount of melatonin
that's listed on the bottle.
They contain either much,
much more or much, much less.
And that melatonin is a potent hormone
that has impacts on not just sleep,
but on other hormone systems as well.
The supplements that I've suggested
and that I personally take
in order to improve my sleep
are magnesium threonate,
spelled T-H-R-E-O-N-A-T-E.
And interchangeably with that
one could use magnesium bisglycinate.
I do consider those interchangeable
because both cross into cells
and cross the blood brain barrier
in much the same way that
makes them better candidates
for improving sleep
than some of the other forms of magnesium.
So magnesium threonate,
theanine, T-H-E-A-N-I-N-E,
theanine, and something called apigenin,
which is essentially
what you find in camomile
that is the reason why
camomile can make you sleepy.
A-P-I-G-E-N-I-N, apigenin.
The dosages for those et cetera
are described in the toolkit for sleep
and why some people might
want to avoid theanine.
I'll just tell you, for those of you
that have very intense
dreams or that might
sleepwalk or have night terrors,
you might want to avoid theanine
because it can enhance
the kind of emotional
and elaborate nature of dreams.
Other people like that.
So I'll take magnesium
threonate, theanine, and apigenin
as a so-called sleep stack
about 30 to 60 minutes
prior to sleep.
I do not take them during the day.
There is, however, another supplement
that used in combination
with the sleep stack
that I just described or alone
can greatly enhance the
quality of your sleep.
And in particular,
people who are following
a low carbohydrate diet
who have trouble falling
and staying asleep seem
to benefit from it,
and that is so-called inositol.
Now, inositol comes in different forms,
but the form that I'm referring to here
in terms of enhancing slow-wave
sleep is myo-inositol.
There are an enormous number
of studies on inositol
for sake of mental health and for sake of
enhancing various aspects
of cellular function
and for sake of improving sleep.
I'd like to just highlight one paper,
title of this paper will make
it clear what it's about.
The title of the paper is
The Impact of Myo-Inositol
Supplementation on Sleep
Quality in Pregnant Women:
A Randomized Double-Blind
Placebo Controlled Study.
Now, as I just told you,
the study was carried
out on pregnant women,
but there have been
other studies of inositol
on other populations.
And the major takeaway from these studies
is that inositol can improve
the quality of sleep and
can adjust the architecture
of sleep in ways that
make it a great candidate
for improving the structure
and maybe also the duration
of slow-wave sleep in particular.
I find that if I'm following
a lower carbohydrate diet,
which I do from time to time,
I sometimes have trouble falling asleep.
Or if I eat four to six
hours prior to bedtime,
then I tend to be pretty
hungry around bedtime.
And sometimes if I'm exercising very hard
or if I'm working a lot,
even if I eat dinner around seven
and I go to sleep around 10:00 PM,
I might be a little bit
hungry still at 10:00 PM.
In that case, I find that
taking 900 milligrams
of myo-inositol in addition
to the other sleep stack
that I just described
greatly enhances my ability
to fall asleep and to get
terrific quality sleep.
I do monitor my sleep.
I do that two ways.
I do that these days with my
Eight Sleep sleep tracker,
and I use a WHOOP sleep
tracker when I sleep.
The combination of those two
taps into different
aspects of sleep tracking,
heart rate variability,
movement, et cetera.
In a future episode, we'll talk about
what are the best devices
for monitoring sleep,
which have certain advantages
and others have disadvantages.
But I certainly see it
in the objective data
that is from the sleep tracking data.
And I also observe subjectively
that taking 900 milligrams
of inositol prior to sleep,
again 30 to 60 minutes prior to sleep,
can greatly enhance the
ability to fall asleep
and for me to stay asleep
throughout the night.
I also noticed another effect,
which is that if I wake up
in the middle of the night
to use the restroom, which I often do,
I find it much easier to fall back asleep.
I don't tend to get into
kind of looping thought
and things of that sort in
the middle of the night.
And that may relate to
the fact that myo-inositol
has been studied in many cases
for its role in controlling anxiety
that is for reducing anxiety.
And that's one of the reasons, in fact,
one of many reasons why
people take myo-inositol
during the daytime.
There are studies of myo-inositol
for dealing with anxiety, for
sleep as we're discussing now,
and even for improving fertility
and things of that sort,
in particular in women.
So again, 900 milligrams of an inositol
can be a useful tool.
60 minutes of exercise,
as described previously,
can be a tool, and
certainly avoiding caffeine
and alcohol is an excellent tool
for enhancing the total
amount of slow-wave sleep.
Jack had a second part to his question,
he asked is having a high level
of rapid eye movement sleep
and a lower level of deep sleep
likely to cause any health issues?
And to be honest, it's not really clear
that it would cause any
specific health issues,
although if we think about
what the specific roles
of slow-wave sleep versus
rapid eye movement sleep are,
again, rapid eye movement sleep
being laden with highly emotional dreams,
It's thought to act as
a sort of trauma release
where people are paralyzed in body
and that's a healthy paralysis,
they're so-called sleep atonia,
but undergoing some pretty emotional stuff
within their dreams,
and there is a lack of
ability for the body
to secrete adrenaline during
rapid eye movement sleep,
that's thought to be important
for emotional repair, if you will,
during the night.
Certainly studies where
people have been deprived
of rapid eye movement sleep
have shown that their
ability to manage emotionally
during the daytime is reduced.
Certainly if you have reduced
rapid eye movement sleep
for multiple nights, that's
going to be the case.
The only caveat to that is
that there are certain forms
of treating depression that involve
specifically depriving people
of rapid eye movement sleep.
That's a whole other
story that was covered
in the podcast episode
with Dr. Nolan Williams.
So if you want to learn more
as to why that's the case,
check out that episode.
But because slow-waves sleep,
which occurs again during
the early part of the night,
is when growth hormones is released
and when there's this periodic washout
of debris within the brain,
and to some extent within
certain tissues of the body,
you could imagine that
reduced low-wave sleep
would lead to reduced ability
to recover from exercise,
from injury, maybe even
relate to the immune system.
However, I am personally
not aware of any studies
that specifically looked at the ratio
of slow-wave sleep to
rapid eye movement sleep,
and that focused in particular
on reduced slow-wave sleep
for bodily repair.
Those studies might be out there,
I was not able to find them.
If you are able to find them,
please put them in the comment section
and I would love to
check out those studies.
So I don't think that one
needs to be overly concerned
if you're not getting a
balance of slow-wave sleep
to rapid eye movement
sleep, that's perfect.
However, and as I mentioned earlier,
it would be good to
strive to try and balance
the amount of slow-wave sleep
and rapid eye movement sleep
across the entire night.
If you think about it,
that will also tell you whether or not
you're getting sufficient total sleep.
And I don't want to open up
another set of questions here
as I'm about to close out
an answer to this question,
but I do often get asked the question
whether or not four hours is enough,
or six hours is enough,
or eight hours is enough.
Well, it's impossible to know exactly
how much sleep each
individual person needs.
And of course, each individual person
will need a different
amount of total sleep
depending on the amount of stress
and physical strain and
various other things
they're dealing with in
their daily waking life.
However, it's generally the case
that kids and people that
are undergoing puberty
and certainly in early infancy
need more sleep than adults do.
So as you age, you do
in fact need less sleep.
One good metric of whether
or not you are getting enough sleep
is whether or not you're sleepy
during the daytime or not.
If you're falling asleep
a lot during the daytime,
you're probably not getting
enough sleep at night.
That's sort of a duh,
but it's an important
duh to pay attention to.
And for those of us, like myself,
that need a 20 or 30 minute
nap in the afternoon, great.
That doesn't necessarily mean
you're not getting enough sleep at night.
So if you get sleepy enough to
want a nap in the afternoon,
that's not an indication necessarily
that you are not getting
enough sleep at night.
However, if you're only sleeping four
or five hours per night,
it's very hard to imagine
that you're getting
a balance of slow-wave sleep
and rapid eye movement sleep.
Once you get into the range
of sleeping six to eight hours
and certainly 8 to 10 hours per night,
the probability that
you're getting a balance
of slow-wave sleep and
rapid eye movement sleep
greatly increases.
So if I were to throw out a number,
I would say for most people,
that is for 95% of people out there,
getting at least six hours
of sleep per night, at least,
and ideally more like seven or eight
is going to be the goal.
However, I've noticed,
for instance, for myself,
unless I'm exercising extremely intensely
or I'm going through a lot of emotional
or physical stress in my daily life,
getting six and a half to
seven hours of sleep per night
allows me to feel really good
and refreshed throughout the day.
And that's especially the case if I get
that 20 or 30 minute nap in the afternoon
or use NSDR, Non-Sleep Deep Rest.
So I hope that answers
your question, Jack,
and there are, of course,
I'm extending the answer to all others
who upvoted that question
or who might be interested in improving
their slow-wave sleep.
There are some dos, there are some don'ts
that I just described.
I suggest trying various things one by one
to see what works best for you
so you don't necessarily need to leap
to doing the 60 minutes of exercise
plus the inositol, et cetera.
However, I do encourage
everyone to avoid alcohol
and caffeine within the 8
to 12 hours prior to sleep.
And again, if you're not
using either of those,
that would be even better,
at least in terms of sleep architecture.
Thank you for joining for the beginning
of this Ask Me Anything episode.
To hear the full episode
and to hear future episodes
of these Ask Me Anything Sessions
plus to receive transcripts of them
and transcripts of the
Huberman Lab podcast
standard channel and Premium Tools
not released anywhere else,
please go to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Just to remind you why we launched
the Huberman Lab podcast premium Channel,
it's really twofold.
First of all, it's to raise support
for the standard Huberman
Lab podcast channel,
which of course will still be continued
to be released every
Monday in full length.
We are not going to change
the format or anything
about the standard Huberman Lab podcast.
And to fund research, in particular,
research done on human beings,
so not animal models, but on human beings,
which I think we all agree is a species
that we are most interested in.
And we are going to
specifically fund research
that is aimed toward
developing further protocols
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
And those protocols will be distributed
through all channels, not
just the premium channel,
but through all channels,
Huberman Lab podcast
and other media channels.
So the idea here is to
give you information
to your burning questions in depth
and allow you the opportunity to support
the kind of research that
provides those kinds of answers
in the first place.
Now, an especially exciting feature
of the Premium channel is
that the Tiny Foundation
has generously offered to
do a dollar for dollar match
on all funds raised for research
through the premium channel.
So this is a terrific way
that they're going to amplify
whatever funds come in
through the premium channel
to further support research
for science and science-related
tools for mental health,
physical health, and performance.
If you'd like to sign up
for the Huberman Lab premium channel,
again, there's a cost of $10 per month,
or you can pay $100 upfront
for the entire year.
That will give you access to all the AMAs,
you can ask questions and get
answers to your questions,
and you'll of course get
answers to all the questions
that other people ask as well.
There will also be some premium content
such as transcripts of the AMAs
and various transcripts and protocols
of Huberman Lab podcast episodes
not found elsewhere.
And again, you'll be supporting research
for mental health, physical
health, and performance.
You can sign up for the premium channel
by going to hubermanlab.com/premium.
Again, that's hubermanlab.com/premium.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[MUSIC PLAYING]